All righ, t so now, we have got these
two Bellman operators, B1 and B2.
That each one is associated
with the a fixed policy.
So B1 makes an update,
essentially following Pi 1.
And B2 makes an update following Pi 2.
So we know a bunch of
things about these updates.
So for example, we know that if we
apply B1 to two value functions.
What's going to happen to
the value functions as a result?
>> They will not move further apart.
>> By a factor of at least Gamma.
>> Unless, they're the same one.
Right?
If they're already perfectly together,
then they won't move closer together.
>> Because they were at a fixed point.
But then their distance is 0.
And we do get gamma closer to zero,
because 0 times Gamma is still 0.
>> Sure.
So that's true, but I'm just saying,
it's not that they always
get closer together.
>> Yeah, okay, all right.
That's fair.
>> Okay.
>> That's fair.
If they are not on top of each other,
then they get closer together.
And the same thing is true of B2.
>> Yeah.
>> But
there's some other interesting
properties of these that aren't
necessarily true of the standard
Bellman operator, but
they are true when we used
the fixed policy like Pi 1 or Pi 2.
So let's step through what
some of those properties are.
And we'll use them to show that
policy iteration behaves itself.
>> Nice.
>> So this is the property that we
want to show that B1 and B2 have.
So, if we've got two value functions,
V1 and V2, not
only if we apply these Bellman operators
to them do they get no farther apart and
actually potentially closer together.
But they actually keep
their same ordering.
So let's say that V1 dominates V2.
So V1 is bigger than or
equal to V2 at all states s.
Then, that still is true after we've
applied Bellman operator B2 or
Bellman operator B1.
But we're talking about B2 right now.
>> Okay, that makes sense and
I think it follows immediately from
raising Thursday to the Monday power.
>> Oh, I see.
No, that's supposed to be theorem.
Sorry about that.
>> Okay
>> We don't do day of the week
math until the next section.
>> Okay, looking forward to that.
>> So how would we show
something like this is true?
The standard thing that we always seem
to do is go back to the definitions and
just plug things through.
And let's see what we get.
>> Okay
>> To show that B2 V1 dominates B2 V2,
I'll just subtract one
from the other and
see if the result is
always non-negative.
>> Okay.
>> So let's do that.
We plug in the definitions.
And I did some cancelling here,
because it's,
it always sort of comes out the same.
This sort of notion that since we're
talking about the same states and
the same actions,
these rewards are going to cancel.
The Gammas and
the summations and the transition
probabilities are going to factor out.
And we're going to end
up with something, well,
actually a lot like this.
Gamma times the sum over all
states of the probability
of reaching the next state times
the difference at the new state,
s prime,
between the value functions V1 and V2.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And what
do we know about this quantity here?
>> Well, we know that V1 is always
greater than or equal to V2,
which means that V1 minus
V2 has to be non-negative.
>> Good, and then we take a convex
combination of a bunch of
non-negative values.
There's no way it could become negative.
>> Right.
>> It could be 0, I guess, but
we know that we're greater than or
equal to 0.
It can't be smaller than 0.
So that gives us exactly what we need.
That if V1 dominated V2 before,
B2 V1 dominates B2 V2 now.
>> Nice.
And if we replaced B2 with B1.
This would also be true.
>> Yes.
Exactly so.
The only thing that we're actually using
here is that we have a fixed policy.
It doesn't matter what the policy is.
So B1 and B2 are the same
operators except they just differ
as to which fixed policy they are using.
>> Okay.
So both B1 and B2 have mono.
That's perfect.
>> No.
They don't have mono.
They are monotonic meaning this preserve
this kind of ordering property.
Not that they have mononucleosis,
sometimes known as the kissing disease.
>> Well, maybe where you're from.